Kylee there they're back together right
they're back together
well Chris a source has told easy that
not only have Kylie and Travis reunited
the parents of two year old daughter
stormy have been back together for about
a month now it's a roller coaster of
emotions
this report corresponds with Kylie
posting a video of her in Travis and a
route to an Oscar party back in February
according to the source the couple took
a break last year on account of their
busy careers including Kylie's
billion-dollar makeup Empire and Travis
being on tour and working on music thank
you the source added quote although
things haven't slowed down much for the
duo they're better able to handle it at
the end of the day the couple is happy
to have their family back together
Kylie they're they're back together
right recently on Ellen momager Kris
Jenner was put on the spot about their
relationship status they're back
together they're just great together
earners yeah they're together a lot well
that's good meanwhile kendall Jenner was
all smiles giving a fun update of her
own this weekend the 24 year old model
posted a video to her into story of her
sisters having full-time with their
children she rode alongside the video
quotes still no kids Wow hilariously
giving a thumbs-up to her followers my
next grandchild will come from but Kris
Jenner also hit it on Ellen to not count
out Kendall having kids in the near
future Courtney alright I really Kylie
what do you think grass with me I think
Courtney we got Auntie well maybe maybe
Kendall
Oh
[Music]